on a josée dayan la réalisatrice
vraiment très talentueuse qui avec nous
au téléphone et ça c'est important
d'avoir son avis là dessus parce que moi
oh là personnellement je vous dis je
trouve ça vraiment pathétique voilà ce
qui se passe là autour de corinne
masiero et du capitaine marleau bonsoir
josée dayan merci d'être mon père pierre
ellien free de m'avoir ali et au
téléphone
bana ba ça me fait plaisir parce que
c'est vrai que franchement se trouve
cette histoire complètement folle moi
c'est quoi qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous mais moi je vais vous dire je suis
comme vous je pense cette histoire
complètement folle jeu j'ai pas
l'habitude de polémiquer je suis pas sur
les réseaux sociaux
et comme disait mon marché quand on
dispute avec un saut en lui cède
toujours mais là les espaces avec ses
députés et le sens tellement ridicule là
je n'ai pas envie de céder j'ai envie de
venir qu'ils ont subi ridicule on est en
train de vivre une période épouvantable
avec ce qu vide avec ses morts avec ses
réanimation au départ est très rare et
d'un seul coup de s'occuper vraiment de
des vrais pros c'est vrai problème dans
les nôtres il va aller faire polémique
pour exécuter pour eux dire qu'il faut
envoyer corps et de mal diront en prison
métier stupide
moi je ou des créanciers a créé
peut-être parler avec vous ce soir je le
fais moi je vous dire ce que j'en pense
je pense une fois de plus et c'est ça
qui me dégoûte mois ils vont ce que vous
dit ce qui fonde la polémique là-dessus
ils se servent de la notoriété de la
popularité de corinne masiero pour qu'on
parle d'eux et pour essayer de buzz et
on est dans une société du buzz on va
pas sortir et même les hommes politiques
les députés
ils veulent avoir du buzz autour d'eux
les deux ou trois qui ont fait ça ils se
disent tiens on va parler de moi parce
que je vais faire un coup d'éclat et ça
c'est grave c'est grave parce que l'a
mérité de la nation leur rôle c'est de
faire des saltos mais aujourd'hui il ya
10 millions de personnes qui sont au
chômage en fait menacé par messi est ce
qu'est ce que tu me dises et sur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage vous je
suis très fier entièrement d'accord avec
vous suis entièrement d'accord avec ce
que vous dites je trouve qu'en effet
c'est un député un sombre députés que
personne ne connaît et qui permet de se
faire une espèce de pitt aurait eu en
attaque encore une
je trouve ça d'une lâche et d'une
stupidité absolue d'autre part on
connaît la position trop rive on sait
qu'ils allaient on sait son courage
pour à toutes ses opinions je vais lui
je le lui ai dit mais elle a au moins le
courage de l'affiché et c'était un as
vraiment fort de sa part et d'autre part
quand il explique le canton semi nu il
faut aller en taule je trouve ça
tellement bête lorsque alors il fallait
mettre tous les chanteurs de r
en prime a bien sûr exactement la
comédie musicale de l'époque
voilà mais josé est ce que vous avez
quelque chose à ajouter
mais j'ai ajouté que vous remercie de
m'avoir invité merci à josé le voulais
je voulais dire cela pour corinne et
merci je sais et continuer ce que vous
faites et vous occupez pas des malades
et des aigris et des jaloux merci
renault clio gamay et ben vous avez
refait donc être bien au revoir josé